well ultimately Aaron Rodgers did Aaron
Rodgers things and CJ Beathard did CJ
Beathard things and that's what decided
this game because Beathard in my view he
just needed to make one big throw in the
fourth quarter and he had opportunities
didn't he have to be able to do you
throw Mike it hit it he just had to make
a throw and instead he made some
mistakes including that last
interception on his last throw of the
night and it was unfortunate because he
played very very well for the most part
for three and a half quarters we're
gonna be talking about that game
obviously plus plenty more over the next
two hours the show is Pro Football Talk
live but it begins right now
[Music]
I don't know if it was a season saving
win for us but it definitely was an
important one especially with the
prognosticating that'll go on about the
type of opponent we have coming up the
next few weeks and obviously them being
road games this was an important game
for us I've never like used the term
must-win but it was an important one
week six ended up being a leather jacket
weekend for franchise quarterbacks we
saw Tom Brady and his leather jacket on
Sunday there's Aaron Rodgers with his
Arthur Fonzarelli homage after the Green
Bay Packers beat the San Francisco 49ers
on a last-second field goal good morning
Peter King it's Pro Football Talk live
NBC Sports Radio NBCSN and look I mean
Aaron Rodgers for most of the night did
not look like Aaron Rodgers and then all
of a sudden it's Aaron Rodgers when it
counts the most
on the game-tying drive and the
game-winning drive and it's the exact
outcome we expected not the way we
expected which made it a very exciting
and memorable game see I think one of
the things that I get every week Mike
when I do this section in my column
called MVP watch and football morning in
America it engenders the most common
every week I mean here we are we've just
finished week six and this is just a fun
exercise I don't know who I'm voting for
for MVP in two-and-a-half months but it
just goes to show you that the
quarterback position in this league is a
paramount interest and nothing really is
close for second and I bring it up this
week because I had golf on my list of
the top five instead of Gurley and
people in LA and otherwise other places
went nuts but I think last night really
showed why in the world the quarterback
position is something that is so frothed
over by everybody who watches the game
loves the game analyzes the game writes
about the game and the San Francisco
49ers had their guy on a fluky play in
Arrowhead
Stadium they lost them for the year and
look I'm probably in the minority and
don't tell people in the Bay Area this
this morning but Mike I think CJ
Beathard was really good last night
you have to consider what CJ Beathard is
he's probably not ever going to be
anybody's franchise quarterback and
overall he played well and he had the
49ers in position to win a game at
Lambeau Field late well and that's right
Peter and look Aaron Rodgers the MVP
candidate made the Aaron Rodgers plays
when the Packers needed him to all the
other players can do whatever their jobs
are supposed to be all game long but the
one guy who affects it the most is the
guy distributing the football in the
passing game Aaron Rodgers did it and CJ
Beathard had opportunities and and as we
talked about in the little TV nub that
we do before the radio program rejoins
the idea that Beth had just needed to
make a throw he had George Kittel open
on a third and four where the 49ers
ultimately settled for three when they
could have gone up by 11 late they had
opportunities multiple times when it was
a field position battle in the fourth
quarter and Beathard never made that
play he never made that throw to extend
the drive to chew the clock and there
was some questionable play call
decisions - there was an opportunity
while driving the ball late when it was
tied 30 30 on second and three run the
ball instead of throw the ball don't
force it into bethards hand keep the
clock running and keep the ball out of
Aaron Rodgers hands I mean it went from
the Packers leaving the 49ers too much
time to try to win the game to the 49ers
leaving the Packers too much time to win
the game with Aaron Rodgers you don't
have to leave him much time at all he
had a minute and seven seconds on his
own 10-yard line went all the way down
to the nine and got the game-winning
field goal and I thought that was one of
the most impressive Aaron Rodgers drives
I've seen the Hail Marys are great but
for him to make the throws he was making
with a look you know it wasn't a win or
lose proposition it was an overtime or
win proposition for the most part but
the throws he was making - on that last
drive that that those are some of the
best throws I've seen from Aaron Rodgers
in a sequence like that you know what is
so special about watching him Mike I was
thinking this watching the
you know the last two three minutes of
the game the word effortless comes to
mind and watching him make throw after
throw after throw not all of them
complete but he is such a flat liner and
and watching him and watching his facial
expression he's I mean the guy's an
assassin he just is he's very very
steely and it's very much put the ball
in his hands he's not gonna get it done
every time but there have been two times
this year this game I mean this throw
right here across his body I mean
obviously you know he's got three he's
got the guy wide open but they're just
several several throws down the stretch
where he throws and it's just like woke
up out of a sound sleep and just throw
the ball and it's it's just he's so
impressive in that way that's so few
other quarterbacks ever give you the
look of that and you know if you watch
his demeanor throughout the course of
the game it almost was like he was
sleepwalking through most of it and you
kind of detect it's always hard to read
someone's facial expression in their
body language but you kind of detected
that oh boy this just isn't our night
what's going on here but if you give him
enough chances all of a sudden he slides
into that assassin role and it's like
all right the whole night has been
pointing toward this let's go do it they
let us hang around and hang around and
hang around they should have delivered
the knockout punch a long time ago let's
go take this thing and you could see
that demeanor change in this in the
blink of an eye I mean it's throw to
Davante Adams has got to go on his list
of I don't know how many ever top-ten
throws that he's made in the NFL in my
opinion I mean first of all if you watch
that replay very very closely Mike you
will see that that ball was missed by
and I forget who was playing defense on
that by the 49ers but that ball missed
his fingertips by 3/4 of an inch if it's
an inch it was a lot I don't think it
was an inch and the ball was perfectly
thrown
and if the cornerback was 6 2 instead of
511 or whatever it is it would have
gotten deflected away it was just he
made a few of those throws last night
where he just shake your head and he say
that is the importance of a quarterback
that is why every general manager is
judged on one thing because he said his
team up with a quarterback long term and
they've had Aaron Rodgers since 2005
he's been the starter since 2008 he
signed for several more years and it
just shows you how important that
position is and now by week coming up
Peter opportunity for Aaron Rodgers to
continue the healing process with that
knee he said after the game that he
hopes he can shed the brace for the next
game coming up which is at the Rams
they've got some tough games coming up
off of the bye at the Rams and then at
the Patriots and then they have a visit
from the Dolphins followed by two more
Road games at the Seahawks and at the
Vikings a tough five-game stretch for
the Packers starting with those
back-to-back games Rams Patriots and I
think we're gonna learn a lot about the
Packers in the two games that they play
coming out of the bye week when I looked
at this schedule at the beginning of the
year Mike I said there's a good chances
of the toughest five-game stretch that
any team in the league has first of all
four on the road
second of all three against teams that
you figure are either certainly gonna
win their division are gonna be prime
contenders and you know right now as I
look at this team I still see a team
that you know they just they've got a
lot of holes the Green Bay Packers
I don't think consistently they get out
they get after the quarterback as well I
think their running game is better than
I thought it was gonna be at the
beginning of the year they're in been
incredibly beat up at the receiver
position but the guy who I can't
pronounce the equi naming this guy what
a catch he made on the sidelines
yesterday MacEwan Amyas Saint Brown it
was a beautiful catch at a crucial time
without that catch I mean really I the
one thing I was thinking is man you got
to give it to Brian gudykunst and the
new front office of this team of the
Green Bay Packers because they drafted
some receivers late and brought in
receivers late who can catch the ball I
go back to the day in the summer where
Aaron Rodgers ripped his young receivers
and I'm saying to myself you know what
that was either a wake-up call or in my
opinion he was absolutely right because
those guys got the message well it
absolutely did work and you're right
they have played very well when needed
and to flip that around it was so
amazing on the last Drive and I know
that 49ers fan robbed stats Carrera is
dismayed and perplexed by this the
Packers have no timeouts and the 49ers
were not guarding the sidelines at all
all those throws all those plays
sideline sideline sideline you make one
tackle in bounds and you have to have
the hobbled Aaron Rodgers trying to line
everybody up to spite the ball they
never had to do that the sidelines were
open it wasn't funneled toward the
middle of the field and that helped fuel
that final drive that won the game you
know what else was interesting I was
looking at this last night after the
game Mike and and you know Aaron Rodgers
a couple of times here's a great example
bouncing around bouncing around bouncing
around and finally he makes that long
run that was such a key to this play and
I think the reason why this worked Mike
is because the 49ers said hey listen
just protect the boundary don't worry
about the middle of the field they're
not throwing it in the middle of the
field but it was a really really smart
play they got a very big chunk there
that they needed and then Rodgers is
able to spike it and then end up going
down to win the game but but I just
thought it was it was a it was the kind
of drive that Aaron wrought that people
loved Aaron Rodgers will look at and say
he knew everything that he was supposed
to do on this Drive even though he
didn't have all his front got frontline
guys with him you know we're talking
about some of the potential flaws for
the Green Bay Packers and I think one
thing we
to mention the defense just got gashed
by the 49ers running game most of the
night and there was a lot of excitement
the arrival of Mike Patton a more
aggressive defense the exact opposite of
a Dom Capers a fiery guy and and the
defense just hasn't gotten to that point
yet
they'll need this by week to try to
fine-tune and improve but if they can
make that defense better and Aaron
Rodgers gets healthy and you have this
revolving door of receivers who can come
in and get it done no matter who's
injured and who's number gets called
this Packers team can still do a lot of
great things it's the second time this
year that they've they've given up an
average of more than five yard to carry
and look the defensive front is too good
for that Mike they've got to figure it
out I think what peten has done and what
I saw last night is that he's trying so
hard to get to the quarterback that
there are times when he leaves himself
light in the run defense and and to me
that's one of the big reasons why
they've been so generous against the run
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports